hello everyone I am very excited to
announce that Richard Roland and I of
universal history Fame we are going to
participate together in doing a class on
Beowulf a Christian interpretation of
Beowulf it will be led by Richard but I
will be there participating hopefully
giving a little bit of my opinion to
Richard tell us what you plan for us I'm
very excited about this first of all
I've always I mean I've actually taught
through Beowulf a couple of times but
this will be the first time I will have
done it in kind of the largest setting
and actually I have a lot more material
that I have than I had since the last
time that I taught through it so we're
going to be starting on Thursday
afternoons uh starting September 7th
meeting weekly for about two hours a
week and there'll be more details about
this on the symbolic World site with all
the the details of wedded wear and
whatnot but basically what we're going
to be doing is reading through the
Beowulf poem I will expose you a little
bit to the uh the poem in its original
language which is of course very
beautiful and in a certain sense the
only way to really read the poem however
this is not an intro to Old English
class so we'll start out each lesson or
each class by reading a little bit in
Old English and then we'll just kind of
go from there to talking about the
readings and basically what we've done
is divided the Beowulf poem up into six
different divisions basically you'll get
everything that you would learn about
Beowulf in the course of like a
university level course but it's going
to be crammed into six weeks in addition
to all of that we're going to be
specifically focusing on it as a work of
medieval Christianity that is something
that was written by a medieval Christian
most likely a monk most likely in the
8th Century of England we're going to
talk about when and where the dating of
Beowulf as I mentioned in the past quite
a contentious uh subject there have
literally been actual fist fights at
conferences about it so I'll tell you
all a little bit more about that but
we're going to be looking at it
specifically as a medieval Christian
text and doing something that actually
most modern day leave list in medieval
studies Scholars won't do which is
looking at it in the context of ancient
Jewish and Christian literature as well
as contemporary Christian literature
around it so it's going to be awesome
and it's going to be a the first time
that we'll have gone really really deep
in terms of the universal history
project as far as like not just sort of
explaining at a high level here here's
how it works but actually looking really
really closely at a case study I'm very
excited about it and my hope is that you
will be too and you'll all sign up and
join us for this and it'll be so
successful that we'll have no choice but
to do like a year and a half of Dante so
that's my that's my uh nefarious plan so
so join us it's going to be the first
version of this is going to be live and
so people will be able to ask questions
you know we'll find a way to have
moderators so that people can ask the
questions in person so we're really
excited to to do this I'm looking
forward to this I love Beowulf and uh
obviously I love our Universal history
series so I will be learning and
engaging and I will be there every week
so uh so go to the symbolicworld.com and
sign up see you all there